from Kerry Washington's silver stunner
to Heidi Klum's red Grecian goddess
ensemble et's running down the Emmy
Awards seven most memorable fashion
moments are you ready for this Eva
Longoria turned heads in 2005 wearing
this coral Angel Sanchez gown the whole
night was magical
in 2006 Heidi Klum showed off some leg
and her growing baby bump in this red
one-shoulder Michael Kors ensemble some
people don't have it Nina Dobrev also
stunned in red at the 2011 Emmys in a
strapless form-fitting Donna Karen dress
and the next year Sofia Vergara wore
this knockout teal Zuhair Murad gown for
me to do while pregnant in 2014
hayden Panettiere shined in a low-cut
Lorena Sarbu for baby bump on full
display
Kerry Washington rocked a Marc Jacobs
sparkling silver frock in 2015 it was
really fun last year Priyanka Chopra
slayed in red donning a flowing at Jason
Wu a one-shoulder chiffon gown
it's my little princess moment today we
can't wait to see what timeless looks
this year's Emmys red carpet will bring
catch all the glamorous looks when it
airs Sunday September 17th on CBS
you